bonsoir bienvenue dans le 20h c'est un
accident dramatique qui s'est produit
cet après midi sur un passage à niveau à
millas dans les pyrénées-orientales un
bus scolaire transportant des enfants a
été percuté à l'arrière par un ter le
bilan est lourd quatre morts sept
blessés graves
le véhicule a été littéralement coupé en
deux hakim abdel khaleq
un car scolaire coupée en deux sous la
violence du choc percuté à pleine
vitesse par un ter pour l'heure des
dizaines de pompiers s'affairent encore
autour des carcasses
il est 16 heures 6 quand le ter à
hauteur d'un passage à niveau situé à
millas non loin de perpignan percute
violemment un bus scolaire transportant
plusieurs dizaines de collégiens
pour l'heure quatre élèves sont décédés
sept sont brièvement blessé une dizaine
d'autres sont légèrement touchés trois
passagers du ter sont également
légèrement contusionnés immédiatement
après la catastrophe
le plan blanc a été déclenché et 50
gendarmes et 80 pompiers sont arrivés
sur place cinq hélicoptères du samu et
de la sécurité civile se relayent pour
transporter les blessés
à millas devant la halle des sports se
sont rassemblés les familles des
collégiens tout attend désespérément des
nouvelles certains ont même tenté de se
rendre sur les lieux du drame
s'est déroulé gendarme derrière le mieux
aider les ambulances privées à moitié du
chbe et là j'étais interdit de penser
les familles sont accueillies dans la
suisse est bien serré mais je rentre pas
parce que moi je suis là grand-mère il
faut que ce soit le père et la mère
depuis qu'accor le premier ministre et
le ministre de l'éducation ont décidé de
se rendre sur place dans une profonde
tristesse et pour l'instant c'est le le
moment d urgence et premier ministre est
en train d'étudier
la façon dont les secours sont en train
d'agir dans un tweet le président de la
république a fait part de sa vive
émotion la mobilisation de l'état est
total at il assuré
et le premier ministre et doit filer
bien arrivée à la mairie de millas où il
doit s'exprimer dans un instant c'est là
qu'on retrouve notre envoyé spécial
elise terne bonsoir élise quelles sont
les dernières informations
eh bien écoutez effectivement un besoin
de voir le premier ministre edouard
philippe se diriger à l'intérieur de la
mairie de millas il devrait y avoir une
réunion avec la préfecture et la
gendarmerie
compte tenu de la gravité de l'accident
d'autres membres du gouvernement sont
attendus sur place d'ici quelques heures
et peut-être demain à deux pas de la
mairie les familles elles se pressent
près de la halle des sports afin
d'essayer d'avoir des informations
l'identité des enfants décédés n'est
toujours pas connue il y à 24 blessés
qui eux ont été répartis à l'hôpital de
perpignan et la clinique saint pierre
afin d'être soigné certains sont dans un
état d'urgence absolue sur les lieux de
l'accident 70 sapeurs pompiers sont
toujours à l'oeuvre merci élise comment
un tel accident at il pu se produire
le passage à niveau et est il
suffisamment sécurisé que sait-on du bus
qui transportait les enfants les
réponses avec aïcha latine m
la photo a été prise 15 minutes
seulement après la collision on y
découvre le bus accidenté
percuté de plein fouet comment ce bus
scolaire at il pu entrer en collision
avec un ter ce que l'on sait c'est qu'il
devait conduire des adolescents pris en
charge au collège christian bourquin
situé dans la petite ville de millas
pour les déposer
4,7 kilomètres plus loin sur la commune
de saint féliu d'avall
dix minutes de trajet tout au plus un
bus scolaire affrété par l'agglomération
de perpignan mais qui appartient à une
compagnie toulousaine la société fort le
chauffeur est employé par cette même
société
quel passage à niveau at il traversé il
s'agissait d'un passage à niveau banal
le voici avec deux demi barrières et des
feux juste devant sur les quinze mille
qu'il existe en france onze mille sons
de ce type selon la sncf
celui de millas n'était pas
particulièrement accidentogène à cet
endroit précis le ter devait rouler à 80
km ray d'après les premières
constatations de la sncf il respectait
les limitations de vitesse
[Musique]